Norse mythology tells the story of jormungan a
Great Serpent so long that it wraps itself the
entire way around midgard and bites its own tail
Legend says that when yorman Gunther unclasps its
jaws and starts to unfurl it will signal the
beginning of Ragnarok the destruction of the
world and that was about as much information as
the foundation gave to agent Nielsen when they
assigned him to his watch Duty in Greenland
in the frozen tundra all day every day he
had been equipped with a sniper rifle thermal
goggles and put up high in a watchtower if he
saw anyone anyone he had to shoot on sight no
questions asked whether it was his Squad mates
the Brigadier general or even his own mother if
anyone walked across the barren stretch of ice
ahead of him he was to shoot them dead under
no circumstances was anyone allowed to enter
that cave the fate of the world could depend
on it but it was cold and the days were long
for months he'd been sitting there by himself
without seeing a single soul walk across the
glacier that's why it took him so long to spy
the figure stumbling across the ice half a
kilometer away but the person didn't look any
clearer when agent Nielsen took a look through
his thermal binoculars barely registering as
much warmer than the snow around him the man
stumbled forward seemingly unaware of the world
around him could this be the start of the Swan
Song of the world is this what he had been warned
about without a moment's hesitation agent Nielsen
snatched up the sniper rifle and readied his
sights on the man some were buried deep beneath
the Greenland ice is one of the most dangerous
scps that the foundation has ever come across to
say that scp-722's Reawakening could spell the
destruction of human civilization is no idle
concern classified as a cutter level SCP scp-722
has been nicknamed jormungandra after the Norse
myth researchers speculate that the creature's
existence could in some way linked to the early
origins of the story of the Norse creature 722 was
brought to the foundation's attention relatively
recently environmental activist group Greenpeace
was shooting a documentary on the effects of
global warming on glaciers in Greenland a small
crew including a director producer three camera
operators and a sound recordist headed out to get
some close-up footage from amongst the glaciers
walking from ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked like deep
Ice Caves surmising that these openings were only
accessible to them because of the melting Glacier
Ice the crew climbed down into the cave to get
some never-before-seen footage some of the footage
of their exploration has been recovered since
and in the background of several shots as they
are adjusting exposure and pulling Focus you can
hear the producer and director theorizing about
where these caves have come from they initially
seem to think that the caves are Millennia old
preserved by Sub-Zero temperatures but soon
they come across several markings on the walls
ancient hieroglyphs and symbols none of the crew
were language experts and so in the footage you
can hear them struggling to identify which people
group would have carved those into the ice walls
in the decades since language experts from around
the world have studied these markings on those
walls and have still been unable to identify any
discernible links to any known human script most
agree that it does seem to predate the settlement
of the island by Eric the Red at the start of the
11th century during this period it is believed
that there were no human settlements on the
island so the origins of this script remain
unknown as the footage goes on you may start
to notice something that the Greenpeace crew
does not one of the ice walls is no longer a
wall at all it looks like a rock in some of the
footage but whenever a flashlight Shines on its
surface you can see a pattern to it scales then
an opening at the far side of the tunnel the crew
emerges into an enormous Cavern estimated to be
upwards of 200 meters in height and several times
wider even their powerful flashlights struggle to
cut through the darkness inside that's the point
that the sound recordist notices the scales
running alongside them as the camera pans you
see that they have been walking alongside a tail
several times taller than them a tail that snakes
its way through the darkness of the cavern to
meet a hulking mass at the other side shrouded in
darkness that is where the footage cuts off those
Greenpeace filmmakers were next seen in a local
town that evening none of them had the chance to
extol the wonders of what they'd encountered that
day as they were all sick a couple went straight
to bed in their lodgings complaining of intense
headaches and exhaustion others tried to check
themselves into the ER but never made it each of
the crew died of different causes necrosis of the
skin internal bleeding kidney failure by 9 pm that
day all of them were dead fortunately there just
so happened to be a low-level Foundation agent
staying in the same guest house says them who
heard the commotion within two days a perimeter
was established within two years the foundation
gained the bulk of knowledge of this SCP that
they rely on to this day it is unknown exactly
how large scp-722 actually is a hulking serpent
half buried in ice much of its body cannot be
observed its sleeps coiled up in the middle
of the cavern that the filmmakers happened across
some of its bodies buried beneath fallen in parts
of the caves others frozen into the ground around
it however based on what can be observed of this
SCP it is estimated to be in the ranges of 8 to
12 kilometers from head to tail fortunately for
just about everyone including you this SCP appears
to be dormant at no time since its Discovery has
this SCP been observed to move make a sound
or otherwise indicate Consciousness sensors
are installed in the chamber to monitor its life
functions and study its heart rate temperature
brain activity and more one concern to the
foundation is that since its Discovery 722 has
had a 0.9 uptick in neural activity researchers
hope that this is just a natural part of this
sleep cycle and that it will return to a deeper
Slumber soon that is the hope at least so what
makes this SCP so dangerous then if it's sound to
sleep well let's go back to agent Nielsen steering
through the scope of his rifle the barrel kicked
back a puff of warm smoke there and gone in cold
air he watched just long enough to confirm the
kill before radioing back to command what he
had observed within an hour the cleanup crew
arrived riding on snowmobiles they waited at
a distance for an hour before approaching the
body rather unceremoniously they wrapped it up
in a black plastic bag strapped it to the back of
their snowmobile and took it away for cremation
Nielsen just sat there in his Watchtower the
whole time observing it all the person looked
sick and not the kind of sick that you'd get from
spending too much time out there on the ice there
skin had gone rotten like they had gangrene or
leprosy it wasn't just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a jumpsuit standard
issue for d-class personnel only a vial held in
their cold dead fingers was any kind of clue for
Nielsen as to what had been going on in that cave
but that was as close as the agent ever came
to understanding the mysteries of scp-722 the
vial however was in many ways all he needed to
know that is because contained in that vial was
a sample of the liquid secreted by 722 it is a
liquid that the Greenpeace crew came into close
contact with when they found the creature and it's
a liquid that promises and denies great power and
great risk to the foundation any and all attempts
to study this liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact with it will
immediately suffer acute sickness interestingly
however there seems to be little consistency as
to how this sickness manifests itself some develop
a number of cancerous cells whilst others lose
cognitive function due to brain swelling symptoms
seem to vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very difficult
hazardous material suits have been deployed for
researchers attempting to study it but have all
failed despite being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive threats how
the substance is able to infect them is unknown
sadly a good number of scientists had to die to
make this discovery another route of study is to
take the substance out of the cave and observe
it under laboratory conditions this was what agent
Nielsen observed as he shot and killed the d-class
Personnel emerging from the Cave the d-class had
been sent in to retrieve the vial of the substance
for external study while a safe and direct route
of entry and exit had been planned for the man to
take he became critically ill whilst in contact
with 722 and developed an aggressive fever no
longer coherent over the radio he dropped out
of signal wandering through the tunnels for two
hours until emerging out of an exit high up on the
glacier two agents with higher security clearance
were dispatched to deal with the body the reason
for their weight was for their own safety 722's
toxin appears to denature with time away from
its source causing it to weaken in potency if
they had approached immediately they may have
well suffered similar Fates to the d-class they
survived but the sample was ruined all subsequent
attempts have also been met with failure it seems
almost impossible to capture a clean sample and
transport it any kind of distance with this toxin
the foundation would have possession of an immense
biological weapon akin to the discovery of the
atom bomb but as of right now all it's good for is
killing d-class Personnel initially the foundation
believed the fluid to be a defense mechanism for
the SCP something to protect it in its deep sleep
but the more time is spent observing it the
more time claim this perception is Shifting
scp-722's toxin appears instead to be a weapon
as such the containment of this creature is of
Paramount importance there are eight known access
points into the tunnel Network that would Grant
access to scp-722 each of them has been sealed
with reinforced gates with additional layers of
soundproofing at regular 4-Hour intervals nitrogen
gas cooled to a near liquid state is to be pumped
through these doors without fail it is believed
that the creature is a form of proto-reptile and
so is theoretically cold-blooded its internal
temperature is dictated by its surroundings
therefore by keeping a cool average temperature
in these caves it is thought that this SCP Slumber
can be prolonged how long is unclear with Rising
global temperatures year after year the threat
that the Greenpeace activists worth proclaiming is
very real just perhaps not quite in the way they'd
envisioned Not only would there be an increase
in natural disaster features and a decrease in
biodiversity there would also be a 12 kilometer
snake roaming around the planet killing anyone in
its path not ideal as such the foundation has also
planted a number of Highly skilled individuals in
prominent environmental positions in the hopes of
turning the tide of global warming sooner should
the ice in that cave system warm by even a couple
of degrees who knows what kind of Spike they might
see on the neural monitors this SCP naturally
is buried deep beneath layers and layers of
security clearances too only in exceptional
circumstances and for Vital maintenance is
anyone allowed to approach this SCP a minimum of
two level three clearance agents are required to
sign off on any such Works in recent years a new
Brigadier General took charge of the containment
operations of scp-722 after his predecessor was
stripped of his duties overly zealous experiments
and increasingly desperate attempts to harvest or
synthesize the 722 toxin saw an alarming uptick
in neural activity over 40 d-class Personnel were
processed and disposed of within a two-week period
in an attempt to assemble a micro laboratory
within the main chamber itself this project
failed and the noises of construction threatened
the piece that had so long been maintained beneath
the glacier the new Brigadier General is taking
no such risks enforcing a zero tolerance policy
on anyone approaching site 103 unless suitably
cleared a number of hikers have sadly had to be
killed this way but the foundation believes it
to be a necessary sacrifice to keep the peace
it is quite easy to find a convincing backstory
for their untimely deaths and the lack of bodies
to bury just another person to get lost and fall
down a crack in the glacier warning stories that
are shared and planted in local towns and on
the internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that researchers
have stumbled across a link to a group of animals
found halfway around the world monitor lizards
of the genus varanas seem to share a similar
set of traits to scp-722 namely the nature of
their toxins you may be familiar with the bite
of a Komodo dragon while the initial wound sure
does hurt the real damage comes in the following
hours and days as necrosis sets in from the
toxins in its mouth could these creatures
share a common ancestor could 722 be the common
ancestor as of right now it is just a hunch but
it's one that has taken root amongst the research
staff in order to find out more though they need
samples tissue samples taken straight from the
SCP itself the only way to do back is to go back
into the caves and start cutting if a bit of
construction noise was enough to raise brain
activity by 0.9 percent taking a hunk of Flesh
could prove a whole lot more dangerous not least
for the Personnel involved who will all have
to sacrifice their lives the potential benefits
could be huge a way to study fatal diseases in
a new light perhaps finding a way to reverse
engineer cures to some of the deadliest conditions
on the planet or perhaps the missing ingredient to
synthesizing the most powerful biological weapon
in human history maybe worst of all it could all
trigger The Reawakening do you remember how the
story of yormangan dorenz with a prediction that
when the Great Serpentine coils the end of the
world Ragnarok itself will arrive but that's
just an old fairy tale right now go check out
scp-3000 and atashisha and what is the biggest SCP